just meters apart for each other no just
in level flight either they're big
things like this
here at the right now as we fly the BAE
Systems Hawk team art one powered by the
rolls-royce the door engine we flown
them here on the red era since 1980
which is obviously a reasonable time but
they are perfect for what they do they
are sprightly they're fast they're
simple to operate and there are pilots
aircraft today we're going to have seven
aircraft of our total of nine in the
display we Phi six to eleven feet apart
in the air we're doing actually about
four hundred miles an hour the skill of
formation flying is essentially
triangulating a position so you have two
references that you're looking at one at
the front and one at the back of another
aircraft and as long as you line up both
of those references perfectly you will
be in the exact formation position we
trained for approximately seven months
before we even display anywhere near the
public we fly the same display for
almost four months of those seven and
it's a building block approach to get us
to the stage where we are absolutely
safe professional my job as a team
leader is to enunciate all the team
pilots where I'm going and when I'm
going to do it we have a very metronomic
radio voice to let them know
holding the bank now everything is done
on that cadence and the guys know when
I'm going to make that in put the actual
art of formation flying in itself is
reasonably straight forwards the
relative motion between the aircraft is
meant to be zero and the only time that
we have any relative movement between
the aircraft is when we're asking the
pilots to change shape for the pilots
who are up there whilst there might be
upside down at a hundred feet to them
the other aircraft don't look like
they're moving at all so you can be too
high or too low which we call too
shallow or deep you can be too far
forwards or too far backwards which we
call short or long and of course this
being a three-dimensional game you can
be too close or too tight as we call it
or too far away from the other aircraft
which is what we call wide but it's also
about timing so we're trying to as
they're in arrows make it look like
we're one wing that's moving beautifully
in graceful formation and to do that the
guys who are furthest away from me as
the leader need to know when I'm going
to turn I expect them to have already
started putting their inputs if they're
a long way away from me and if they
don't they're behind the time and it's
going to look like a broken chair every
formation shape and every formation
position has a different route to get
out of that formation quickly and safely
enough and they're what we call the
escape strategies but every maneuver is
different so the pilots are not only
remembering which manoeuvres next but
also how to escape from that maneuver
when it's coming up the pilots here on
my team of an inordinate amount of trust
in each other they have a prescribed
piece of airspace next to the aircraft
that they're for mating on that's what
we call the box and the pilot who's
flying next to them trusts that they are
never going to be outside of that box of
formation
[Music]